in principle gene-editing means it just
like you can go into a word processor
and erase a word from what you've
written and you can change that word for
a different word the technologies are
beginning to allow us to go into a cell
change its internal code or vocabulary
which would be its DNA in its genome and
answering to for a human cell and you
can switch out the word change the word
with certain caveats who should we
intervene on what are the limits who are
who gets to decide what normalcy versus
abnormal she is who gets to decide
whether someone is you know what what
suffering is you could give an example
of for instance of it let's see a
terrifying lethal disease which you
could detect in an embryo before
implanting it and decide that that's not
the embryo that you want to implant but
that depends on you and I saying that's
a terrifying lethal disease and that's a
decision that you and I need to make
them I really mean society needs to make
in consensus so it's a time to emphasize
that idea that we're making decisions
like this really this issue came to a
head when researchers in China decided
to take non-viable human embryos and
decided to try to attempt changing a
disease linked gene and that non-viable
human embryo set it they were important
it's important to note that they were
non viable in the long run but it's also
important to note but that they were
indeed human embryos or very early human
embryos and that the proof of principle
experiment was launched so it's it's
created a worldwide set of questions
about what we can and cannot do with the
human genome the wrote eugenics was was
paved with the best intentions and it
was a series of you can almost see the
world tipping towards horror step by
step by step you know it seemed like one
iterative step didn't seem that much and
yet as you accumulated all of these very
soon you went from you know in Nazi
Germany in particular starting with
trying to eliminate or sterilize those
who were
somehow physically different from from
others all the way including folks who
were deaf
folks who had various neurological
diseases and then sort of marched
inexorably towards other forms of
identity including obviously Jews
Gypsies homosexuals and so forth so it's
worthwhile remembering that that
progression that occurred in the 1930s
was was perceived by the citizens at
that time as part of a progression it
was not as if you know all of a sudden
someone woke up there was a kind of
glacial silence - the progression of
eugenics in Nazi Germany and in fact
there was a glacial silence from the
United States about what was going on in
Nazi Germany if anything you know folks
in the United States applauded the
eugenicist indices applauded the efforts
of Nazis of Nazi scientists in their
attempts to cleanse the cleanse their
populations of all sorts of evil and
emancipate themselves so it's incredibly
important to remember that history when
we step as we are going to as we're
stepping towards the genetic
modification of human embryos or even to
some extent the genetic modification of
other animals or plants we have to
remember that it seems as if there's a
progression but all of a sudden by the
time from the beginning to the end you
may land up in a very different place
it's it's it's important also not to
throw as we enter new genetic
technologies not to throw the baby out
with the the genetic bathwater I mean
it's important to remember that there's
that our ability to manipulate genes can
be very powerful it has been very
powerful